[Musique]
julien un nouveau jeu sur sa console la
guerre de l'espace dans la boutique en
ligne
il ya plein d'autres personnages qu'il
faudrait bien essayé mais il faut payer
il arrive à attendrir son père qui
consent à lui acheter un personnage mais
le père ne prend pas le temps de lire
que l'entreprise de jeux conserve son
numéro de carte de crédit pour faciliter
de futurs achats julien que maintenant
accéder quelques clics à l'univers
apparemment infini du crédit de son père
jusqu'au jour où papa reçoit la facture
comme le dirait gianluca il sent monter
en lui le conte pierce cure de la
connais je suis ton père
mais il n'a pas le choix de payer par la
suite une vie riche les renseignements
de sa carte de crédit dans le compte de
julien fin mot de l'histoire
ne laissez pas une carte de crédit dans
l'attirail d'un petit jedi